now let's have a look at these are new
pieces of work I say new work but
they're kind of not really new work
they're just like we've been doing
before it's just like there's more
pieces around the key that we have to
get rid of right okay so look at this
one over here I've gotta get this guy by
himself
right ah but there's some of them over
there it's almost like it's almost like
the Kings kind of split himself in two
and we need to get it all in one place
first so what could I do to both sides
that would get the key in one spot yeah
Brandon okay whoa you've done a couple
of things first there so you've got this
18 over here you want to get rid of the
18 okay so okay so if I take away six
for both sides I'm gonna write that down
and maybe you guys want to follow with
me okay we'll take away six for both
sides
that's gonna get rid of this six on this
side that's good okay so I'm gonna write
that with the right color that's three
okay and that leaves me weird okay now
what's happened to the a on this site
not our entire question what's happening
nothing's happened to right he's still
just hanging out there okay but the 18
and the minus six they're like terms
aren't they so they leave us with will
hold on product before we can get to
that but what's happening over here then
finished off is very good plus 12 okay
so now I've gone a step further but I'm
still I start this tic King he's kind of
in two spots at the moment so I want to
get him in one of these two spots right
we usually like to end with the King on
the left and our pronumeral on the left
so I'm gonna try and keep this one yeah
get rid of that one got him what would
you do
okay I've got one eight here right and I
don't want a member there do I I want
everything over this side so if I take
away an A from here and take away they
from there right same thing to both
sides everything about it so 3a take
away one a these
right how many 80s my left with on the
right no they all disappear and I just
have that 12 okay one last thing to do
we've been in this position before I
should divide by two very good so divide
by two divide by two and that leaves us
with six okay so you can see each time
what I did to both sides always keep
things balanced out why don't you have a
go at this next one
watch out for that and white is fine in
front of the 6x
now we've seen before there's lots of
different ways to go with these two
approach these equations just because
your way might have started off with a
different step that's okay so one has
this number you can pop back into your
first line remember that's how we check
a solution right as long as you can pop
that back in whichever way you got about
it
it's like okay so let's have a go my
instinct is actually for this question
to start it off just like I did this
question because I see that six over
there you see that so I'm going to go
take away 6 take away 6 okay as you see
as you start to get more confident you
don't necessarily have to write this
extra step in but I want to really make
sure that we know what we're doing and
I'm not accidentally taking away the
wrong thing all right on the left-hand
side you can tell me what do I end up
with yep the sixes the plus and the
minus they eliminate each other and then
on the right hand side just take my 6x
is still just hanging out there what
happens over here plus 50 very good
all right now here I'm in that position
before where I've got the X's on both
sides right I want to collect like terms
I want the King just in one spot over
there on the Left I've got a minus 6x
there what's the opposite of minus 6x
here Daniel plus 6 it's very good so if
I add 6x here so these will disappear
course you do something one side so you
don't do it to the other right so
there's my plus 6x okay four of them
plus six them in total I've got 10 of
them 10 of the X's okay over here the
reason why we chose this is to make
those guys disappear
which leaves you read 50 and I bought
one last step right all right
that's okay what's the last step divide
by 10 right I think is so good at this
I'm looking to do the extra writing when
you divide 50 by 10 you're just left
with okay now let's just double check
because a few people of different
answers let's make sure we know that
that works over here on the top line 4x
plus 6 and minus 6x plus 56 let's see if
5 works out okay so for instance 4 times
5 plus 6 order of operations which one
do i do first
I knew x first right so that becomes
reading 20 and then I add the 6 okay now
what do I have on the right well let's
put in x equals 5 and see what happens
if I go minus 6 times 5 plus 56 again
order of operations I do the times first
when I get from this - faith - 30 I add
56 sure enough I'm getting 26 now watch
out for that minus sign because what -
what's + so that's why I end up with my
26 ok it checks out alright last example
you drew on the board together this time
I will ask you to pick up your pens and
do this with me because um it's a little
bit different there's something of it's
thinking about it okay yeah okay that's
a great suggestion
I've got this plus 6 over here I already
wanted it I see a lot of plus 6 is
around I'm gonna get rid of that this
coincidence okay so if I take away 6
here I should take away 6 here is that
alright let's see if we can do this part
in our head that'll become nothing I
just get left with minus 3q right don't
forget the minus sign makes all the
difference right when I take away 6 from
this part a take away 6 is to take away
Q right so far I haven't added in these
extra red bits we're just doing it in
our heads if you feel confident this is
where you're gonna start getting - hmm
all right now what do I usually do at
this point what am I do it these two
yeah I know yeah good the pretty rules
are in two different spots let it
collect like terms I've got a minus Q
over here that's the opposite of minus
customer I'm gonna add Q very good when
I add a single q to this side I've got -
three of them someone I add one I'll
have - two of them left right and of
course when I add it over here the Q's
just cancel each other out
that leaves me - all right all one was
finished but what's thinking about this
is that negative right so I know you
just want to get rid of the two I want
to get rid of a negative as well so I'm
going to divide both sides by negative
two it's a decade the negative as well
on the left-hand side that'll leave me
just with Q when I divide two by
negative two
hmmm now the twos will give me justice
one but there's a negative in there
right so there's going to be a minus one
now I can test this out just try to get
to your question more let's just quickly
test this guy up here different color on
the left-hand side I'm gonna get six
take away three three what three lots of
minus 1 right what's minus 3 times minus
1 what happens - there's two negatives
they cancel third thing right so I get 6
plus 3 you see how those negatives have
crashed into each other 6 plus 3 of
course is 9 let's see if it works out on
the right hand side say it again that's
right which is why I've gotten this but
here I've got two negatives two
negatives become that positive good
pickup now when I look at the right-hand
side that's that right H take away take
away what -1 and again I've got two
negatives you see that which is 8 plus 1
which sure enough is 9 now then okay so
you can always check you never have to
have any doubt in fact even this part
you could have done with your calculator
it might have been even faster